[Applause]
I grew up on a beef farm in Missouri and
like everybody else that raises
livestock, we raise a lot of our own
feed to stay in business and we raise
corn and soybeans and hay and we grind
this stuff up into a flour and we'd add
vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals. make pellets and you feed
those calves for about six, nine months
and then you ship them off to be
butchered or maybe to other feeders and
you always save back the very best ones
for yourself and you knock them in the
head and eat them. It's a real simple
cycle on the farm. And the thing that
fascinated me as a teenager was that we
went to a great deal of trouble for
those calves and yet as a family we ate
out of the very same fields. We'd keep
back five rows of corn for oursel. We
had a garden at the end of the field
where we grew our peas and beans and
squash and tomatoes and we wanted to
live to be a hundred with no aches and
pains and we didn't give ourselves the
very same vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals that we gave the calves.
And I always used to ask my dad, I'd
say, "Hey pops, how come we go to all
that trouble for those calves and and
not for oursel?" And he'd say, "Shut up,
boy. Getting farm fresh food, fresh air,
lots of free exercise. Don't ask
complicated questions." And I was glad
to get rid of the farm exercise and go
to a school at the University of
Missouri. And there my major was in
animal husbandry and nutrition. My minor
was in field crops and soils. And I
began to learn technical things about
soil chemistry and how it related to
tons and bushels per acre and a
economics. But I didn't get an answer to
my basic question until I became a
freshman veterary student at the
University of Missouri. And there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds, bottom line,
is because we don't have insurance for
them. We don't have Blue Cross, Blue
Shield, major medical hospitalization,
Medicare, Medicaid. And if we were to
use a human health care type of system
for animals, it'd be sticker shock for
you. And your hamburger would cost you
$275 a pound. Boneless, skinless chicken
breast would be $450 bucks a pound.
Dozen eggs would be $50 just to pay for
the health care. So we learned that we
could keep the price of animal products
such as meat and dairy and poultry and
eggs down to where the average American
could afford them simply by
significantly reducing or totally
eliminating health care costs. And we do
that in animals by preventing and curing
diseases with nutrition. Well, after
graduating vet school, I went to Africa
for a couple of years and got to work
with Marlon Perkins from the old Mutual
of Omaha Wild Kingdom days. That was
kind of a kick. Got to play Frank Buck,
use a tranquilizer gun, all over
Central and South Africa for a couple of
years. And then Marlon sent me a
telegram and invited me back to the
States. Uh he'd gotten a 7.5 million
grant from the National Institutes of
Health and this was more than 30 years
ago. And this was to study pollution and
ecology and the environment. And my job
as the wildlife veterinarian on the
project was to do autopsies of animals
that died of natural causes in the big
zoos around the United States. And I was
supposed to identify or find a species
of animals that was ultra sensitive to
pollution. And we're going to use that
animal much like the old coal miners
used to use canaries. You know how that
goes. They take the canary down in the
mine and if methane gas or carbon
monoxide were to leak in the mine, the
canaries were more sensitive than the
men and uh would drop off the Persian
die and long before the men were in
danger of suffocating or blowing up.
Well, to make a long story short, after
some 12 plus years of working on this
project, I had done some 17,500
autopsies and over 454 species of
animals plus 3,000 human beings for a
comparison. And what I learned was that
every animal and human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency disease. And I got kind of
excited about nutrition again. And I
wrote 75 scientific papers on the
subject. Uh wrote chapters for eight
multi-author textbooks. Actually
contributed a textbook myself, a
thousand pages, 2,000 illustrations. and
uh through the news releases that were
in the big universities I worked with. I
was on 2020 was in 1,700 newspapers
around the world through the UPI and AP
newswire services and with all this
public exposure and with all this
scientific exposure I couldn't get
people who are in a position of
authority either in medical research or
in politics to get too concerned or
interested in preventing and curing
diseases in human beings with nutrition
just like we did in animals. Well, I got
frustrated enough I went back to school
in Portland, Oregon, became a physician,
and I practiced there for 12 years as a
general family practitioner, and uh I
sewed up chainsaw wounds, delivered
babies, um used everything that I'd
learned in veterinary nutrition on my
human patients. And it was no surprise
to me that it worked just as well in
people as it did in animals. Well, to
get started, I always like to talk about
longevity. And the human being has the
genetic potential to live healthily, to
be 120. And I'm going to prove that to
you in just a minute. Unfortunately,
Americans do a lousy job when it comes
to longevity. Our average lifespan in
the United States is 75.5, about half
what we're genetically capable of. In
1990, when the World Health Organization
examined the top 32 industrialized
nations on Earth, the United States came
out 17th. There was actually 16 other
countries whose peoples live longer than
we do. We ranked 19th in healthfulness.
That meant that there were 18 other
countries whose peoples live longer than
we do before they develop heart disease
and cancer and diabetes and arthritis
and osteoporosis. We ranked 23rd when it
came to live births and first year
survivability as a babies. And we ranked
dead last 32 out of 32 when it came to
preventing birth defects. Now what all
this means is we have the highest price
health care system in the world but not
the best. It also means that we have the
most envied health care system in the
world but not the best. We have the most
technologically advanced health care
system in the world, but not the best. I
had a good friend by the name of
Christopher Bird for many, many years,
over 20 years. And Chris was a
best-selling author on books on
organically grown food. He was an expert
in this subject. And I was always trying
to give him vitamins and minerals, and
he refused to take them. And he tell me,
"Doc, I bring my own cooler. I don't eat
any uh hotel food. I bring my own
organically grown food. And so, I don't
need to take vitamins and minerals."
Well, I was changing planes uh again in
Atlanta. Had an hour to kill. picked up
the local newspaper and guess whose
obituary I found in the newspaper? Chris
Bird. Of course, again, he was a
best-selling author of books, The Secret
Life of Plants, The Secrets of the Soil.
And he died at age 68 from a ruptured
aneurysm, a type of stroke, seven and a
half years before the average American
dies. And he led a pristine life, lived
up in the mountains, had an organically
grown garden, collected herbs, you know,
like Ule Gibbons and ate wild hickory
nuts and all those kind of things. And
because of his belief, he died of a
copper deficiency. And I'll show you in
a minute that copper deficiency causes
ruptured aneurysms. And it's just a
tragic thing that that people have so
much to give and die at less than half
their genetic potential for longevity. A
lot of people say to me, "Doc, I don't
need to take vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals because I use herbs."
Now, herbs are not nutrition. You have
to understand that herbs are not
nutrition. They are great plant
medicines. Uh they're safer, they're
more economical, in most cases are more
effective than prescription medications
that doctors will give you. But they're
plant medicines. If you have diarrhea,
they can tighten you up. If you have
constipation, they can loosen you up. If
you have hypertension or high blood
pressure, they can bring it down. If you
have a fever, then bring it down. But
don't expect to get enough calcium or
selenium or boron or copper or vitamin A
from herbs. Well, I've been doing
biomedical research and clinical
research in animals and human beings.
And I can tell you no matter how you
look at health and longevity, whether it
be in animals or human beings, there's
only really two concepts you have to
deal with. Concept number one I refer to
as avoid stepping on the landmines. This
is where you don't want to throw away
your healthy physical body wastefully.
You don't want to smoke. Don't abuse
alcohol. Don't do drugs. Don't jog down
the highway at 2:00 in the morning
wearing an all black ninja suit. You're
going to get hit by a truck mirror.
Right? Whenever a doctor says, "Here's
our options." Never say, "Doc, whatever
you say, you're the you're the doctor."
When a doctor says, "Here's our
options." What you want to do is say,
"Look, I want copies of all these
records and test. I want copies of the
X-rays." And go visit three other
doctors and three other hospitals. You
want to talk to 12 of their living
patients that had gone through this
procedure. Talk to them. See if you
really want to do this. I mean, you do
this for your driveway and your roof and
your fence and your yard and all that
kind of stuff. Why not for your own
physical body? That's concept number
one. Now that you've avoided the
landmines, you're in a good position to
do all the positive things that you need
to do to go on to live to be over 100.
Basically, what you want to do is take
all the essential nutrients. 60, that's
six O minerals, 16 vitamins, 12
essential amino acids, and three
essential fatty acids. They're called
essential nutrients for two reasons.
Number one, your body cannot manufacture
them. You must consume these every day,
either as food or supplements. Number
two, if any one of these essential
nutrients is missing for a couple of
months, couple of years, you get on the
average 10 deficiency diseases. You have
everything to gain, nothing to lose by
supplementing properly. Well, the
medical profession of course has this
malignant dumb belief that you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups. My favorite article of all time
in the press was April 6th, 1992. Time
magazine cover article, the real power
of vitamins. New research shows it may
help fight cancer, heart disease, and
the ravages of aging. Six positive
pages. If you haven't read it, I'd urge
you to go to a public library, school
library, dig it out, and read it. There
was only one negative sentence and as
you might guess it was offered by a
medical doctor who was actually uh
contacted by the writer of the article
said, "What do you think about vitamins
and minerals and and trace minerals as
supplements for human nutrition?" Here's
what he said. Quote, "Popping vitamins
doesn't do you any good?" sniffs Dr.
Victor Herbert, a professor of medicine
at New York City's Mount Sinai Medical
School. We get all the vitamins we need
in our diets, and taking supplements
just gives you expensive urine." Now,
Missouri translation of that is, "You're
just peeing away your money. You might
as well wind up your dollars, throw them
in a toilet, and flush them away. You
can get everything you need from your
four food groups is what he's trying to
say. Well, I'd rather pee out 50 cents
or a dollar a day worth of excess
vitamins and minerals. That's cheap
insurance. Think about it. How much
money you spend for coffee or soft
drinks or newspapers and that kind of
stuff every day. 50 cents to a dollar a
day to maintain and repair your body.
And it's kind of fascinating that most
people don't do it. Just remember when
you pay that doctor out of your own
pocket or indirectly through insurance
or indirectly through taxes and
Medicare, Medicaid, not a single penny
of that goes to better understand,
manage, treat, prevent or cure
catastrophic diseases in kids, breast
cancer in women, prostate cancer and
men. And a lot of people asked me, why
did you call your original tape deads
don't lie? Well, that's because I I
believed for a long time because I'd
done medical research for over 20 years
in large medical research institutes,
medical schools, the various
laboratories, and I always had a belief
in the medical system. But I I was very
disappointed when I learned that doctors
don't know the most about health and
longevity. Doctors don't know the most
about disease. They do know about
procedures, you know, how to fix your
bones when you break them and that sort
of thing, how to do a CAT scan. And so I
began to look in the medical journals
and sure enough the first article ever
published on health and longevity of
American doctors was published in JAMAMA
in June 15, 1895, a little over 100
years ago. They said at that time
doctors lived to be 54.6.
I redid the study 97 years later using
the same obituary techniques that they
did in JAMAMA. This was um January 20th,
1993 in that particular issue of JAMAMA.
And it turned out the doctors lived to
be 57.6. I round it up to 58 to give
them the benefit of the doubt. And
doctors just went berserk when I said
that. I mean, this was the most
outrageous thing that they ever heard.
My principle is my my premise is that
doctors don't live as long as the
average couch potato in America. And I
purposely put that figure out there, 58,
to try and challenge people. Well,
doctors immediately looked at all the
insurance actuarial charts. They got
250,000 dead doctors. They said, "Your
group's too small." So they looked at
250,000 dead doctors. They say doctors
don't live to be 58. They died at 62.
They still don't live to be 75.5 like
the average couch potato. We actually
reran this again using the entire
obituary history for 1996. And for the
entire 1996 of all the doctors dying in
1996 with all the medical treatments and
drugs and and procedures and everything
and transplants, doctors in that study
lived to be 70. Still five and a half
years short of the average couch potato
in America. So they still have never
proven that doctors live as long as
everybody else. And that's why dead
doctors don't lie.
Now, if you do everything right, how old
can you live to be? Is it worth all the
effort? I believe it is. Here's one.
Christian Mortonson from San Rafale,
California, in August of 1995, turned
113. August of 1996, he turned 114. He's
still going strong. Certainly can live
to be 115. Smokes a couple of cigars a
day like George Burns, who also lived to
be over 100. Certainly was. I guess the
only exercise George Burns ever did was
put the cigars in his mouth. This gal
here, Dora Ramothi from South Africa in
July of 1995 turned 114. And when she
was asked by the media, Dora, what do
you attribute your health and longevity
to? She did not say that we owe it all
to our annual physical or our HMO. She
said, I ate locust every day. You know,
a little grasshopper. She's not a
vegetarian. She's little animals.
Pumpkin seeds, tortoise meat, wild
herbs, dried fruit, and starts each day
with a cup of coffee. This gal here,
Margaret Skez from Radford, Virginia, in
1994 was the oldest documented living
American when she died at age 115, fell
over and fractured her hip. Three weeks
later, she was dead from complications
of osteoporosis, a simple calcium
deficiency. And we'll talk more about
this in a minute. Unfortunately, this is
not unusual. 75% of all Americans over
the age of 65 who fracture a hip or
major leg bone don't live 90 days. They
die of pneumonia, pulmonary ambolism,
stroke, and other complications of that
fracture. Susie Brunson according to her
family in December of 1994 was the
oldest American when she died at age 123
and they base her claim on her birth
date December 25th 1870 which is
recorded in the family bible. Then this
fellow here, Francisco Barrison Wave at
Choparina October 1995. He was from a
little town outside of Bogota, Columbia,
turned 125. When he was asked by the
media, Francisco, what do you attribute
your health and longevity to, he said,
well, I drink a gallon of goats milk
every day. Also, it's kind of
fascinating in his birthday
announcement. This is not obituary, this
is a birthday announcement, said that
over 40 years ago, his physicians told
him he only had a couple of months to
live. So, he had his sons build him a
coffin. And uh he's been waking up every
morning for more than 40 years sitting
by that coffin waiting to die.
Good. Night time comes, he goes to bed,
wakes up the next morning, sits by the
coffin, waits to die. Now, he's still
going strong. And all the doctors who
told him that more than 40 years ago are
long since dead. Now, this fellow here,
Hammoodi El Abdullah from Syria, died
age 133. And he was still fathering
children after the age of 100. He um
remarried for the fourth time when he
was age 80. Fathered four boys, five
girls, nine children after the age of 80
with the same wife. And you add up the
pregnancies and the breastfeeding, the
time in between pregnancies, he was
still fathering children after the age
of 100. Now, this very next one is my
very, very favorite. This gal, Mazumi
Dusty from Iran, according to the Rocky
Mountain News Wire Services out of
Denver and the Iranian news agency, this
was January of 1995. She died at age
161. Now, you have to give a certain
amount of credibility to this obituary
report that she died at age 161 because
she was survived by six living children
ranging in age from 120 to 128. They
hadn't even left home to go to college
yet.
Now, her oldest son, Golam, said his
mother had never visited a doctor or
taken any chemical medications during
her life did take a few herbs. So, if
you kind of think about it, every one of
these people who live to be over 100,
120, 130, 160. These people are not from
United States or Canada or Germany or
England. Kind of interesting, isn't it?
They're most of them are from third
world countries. They're furthest away
from medical help and they live to be
old. So that we're beginning to collect
information here. The last one we want
to look at the National Geographic
Society, a very respected group of
people, scientists and and so forth and
support groups for science uh comes out
with a monthly magazine, the National
Geographic magazine of course, and they
uh in January of 1973 came out with a
nifty special issue on longevity. They
they looked at cultures whose people
live be 120 and they documented the
oldest living human being that they
could find based on their criteria. This
fellow by the name of Sharali Mismal
from Azerbaijan, a little country just
south of Russian Georgia in western
Russia today. They documented him as
being 167 years old. Remember this is
the National Geographic Society, not the
National Inquirer. 167 years of age and
they had a half-page picture of him
actually harvesting tea leaves in a tea
plantation. Still working eight hours a
day, six days a week when he was 167.
Five months later, May of 1973, Shalley
Misoloff turns 168, goes out and hose
the garden for reporters to show how
vigorous he is. Now, for at least 50,
maybe 70 years, medical doctors in
America have been poo pooing the idea
that you could live well beyond 100. You
know, people who lived 115, 120, they
were one in six billion. It wasn't
something that everybody could look
forward to. And anybody who tried to
teach people how to live to be 110, 120,
140 were considered charlatans and
quacks and taking advantage of uh older
people. I was glad to see this come out.
This was a news article in the USA Today
newspaper in October of 2000 and it was
based on a article in the journal
Science, very respectable journal. And
what they said was, "Forget 100, try
living past 120. Humans possess a
maximum life expectancy longer than 120
years, which has been the long theorized
medical limit. In fact, lifespans appear
to be increasing over time with no end
in sight. Now, the cute part of this is
now that there's no doubt about it,
everybody agrees that human beings,
including Americans, have the genetic
capacity to live well beyond 120.
Doctors want to take credit for it. The
things that have actually increased our
longevity from 45 average lifespan in
1895 to 75.5 today which is an increase
of about 30 and a half years. Our sewers
and good clean water
public health things. We don't have
chalera and leptosperosis and
tuberculosis in our food supply and our
water supply anymore. We have meat
inspection. We have public water works
and things. We have sewers. These are
the things that have extended our
lifespan. Then there's this salt thing.
You know, whether you believe it or not,
this medical dogma has really caused a
lot of problems in America. How many
have you ever heard that using a salt
shaker is bad? You're going to get
hypertension, right? You're going to get
heart disease and stroke. What's the
first thing that a good farmer puts out
for his livestock? A salt block or salt
lick, isn't it? There's nobody out in
the pasture telling a cow she's limited
to one lick a day.
I refuse to believe that my human
patients are dumber than a cow. Say,
"Look, go ahead and pick up a salt
shaker. You're going to see that
lightning won't strike you. You can go
ahead and salt your food to taste. You
can salt your body. Nothing bad's going
to happen. And 98% of my patients love
it. They bring me hundreds of new
patients every month who want to use
salt and not feel guilty about it. And
2% of the bean counters, they say, "Now,
while we love you and respect you, we
have this highriced cardiologist that
says you're flying in the face of all
the weight of medical evidence. You
can't tell people that um they can use a
salt shaker because you're going to kill
them with high blood pressure and heart
disease and stroke." And I've been
vindicated in this belief. This was
actually a study that was published in
the New York Times May 22nd, 1996. And
this study was abstracted from JAMAMA,
the Journal of the American Medical
Association, the most prestigious
medical journal in the world, according
to themselves.
Now, in this particular journal, a Dr.
Alexander Gordon Logan who's an
epidemiologist and cardiologist on the
teaching staff of the medical school at
the University of Toronto up in Canada
and he took 56 existing studies on
hypertension or high blood pressure and
restriction of salt combined the data
from these 56 studies which included 35
people. He threw away all the
conclusions and re-evaluated the larger
group and what he found out was this. If
you have normal blood pressure and you
restrict salt, it will not prevent you
from getting heart disease or high blood
pressure. If you have hypertension or
high blood pressure and you restrict
salt, 97% of those with high blood
pressure or hypertension who restrict
salt will not get any measurable
benefit. 97% will not get any measurable
benefit. Zero. 2 to 5% get measurable
benefit, but it's not significant.
They're only able to reduce their blood
pressure by 3.7 millimeters of mercury.
So, here's what Dr. Alexander Gordon
Logan said in JAMAMA May 22nd, 1996. He
said, "You might as well go ahead and
salt your food to taste. It's a
meaningless exercise. is don't get
paranoid about salt. It has nothing to
do with blood pressure problems. There
has never been one single iod of proof
that restricting salt has any benefit.
It's just one of those medical myths, he
called it, but I'm going to call it a
medical cocka. Now, if it's not salt,
what causes high blood pressure? Well,
it's not salt, first of all, because
salt is an essential nutrient is a
combination of sodium and chloride, both
of which you need. And according to the
American Heart Association, the minimum
daily requirement for 150 lb person for
salt each day is a heaping teaspoon, 6
to9 gram of salt a day. Now, the
Japanese who live longer than we do, the
Japanese who live 4.1 years longer than
we do and have half the cancer rate,
they eat 12 grams of salt a day. They
eat three times the salt we do and they
live four years longer, have half the
cardiovascular disease rate
and half the cancer rate we do. do and
yet they eat three times as much salt as
we do. So, you're beginning to put the
puzzle together that doctors really
don't know what they're talking about.
That's why dead doctors don't lie. Well,
if it's not the salt and if it's not
genetic, what is it? Well, it's actually
just a simple mineral deficiency. Raise
your hand. You ever heard that
cholesterol is bad and you got to get it
low in your blood. You got to have low
cholesterol diet, otherwise you're going
to get heart disease, right? Doctors
would like to blame all cardiovascular
disease on cholesterol. We've known for
75 years in the animal industry that
cholesterol is not a boogeyman. There's
not a single disease that's caused by
elevated blood cholesterol or
triglycerides. If you can find me one,
I'll give you a million dollars in small
bills in any offshore account you want.
There's not a single disease that's
caused by elevated blood cholesterol or
triglycerides. Elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides are really
just a warning signal, much like a
fever. Fevers don't cause infections.
But when you have an infection with a
bacteria, a virus, a fungus, maybe a
parasite, you can get a fever. You can
have a broken leg and get a fever. You
can have cancer and get a fever. You can
have liver disease and get a fever.
Babies get a fever when they tee. And so
you have to kind of sort it out. When
somebody comes into a doctor's office
with a fever, you have to say, "Well,
okay, here's my whole list called a
differential diagnosis. All the things
that cause fever. If they're 80 years
old, you can quickly rule out teething,
right?
But the rest of them you may have to do
some lab tests for." Any rate, the same
thing is true for elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides. When you
have elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides, it might mean that you
have hypothyroidism or low functioning
thyroid gland. You could have diabetes.
You could have deficiencies of niacin,
chromium, venadium, the essential fatty
acids. You could have liver disease. All
kinds of reasons why you might have
elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides, but they themselves don't
cause any problems. Now, the Eskimos
above the Arctic Circle have a
traditional diet. There's 98% red meat
and blubber. Uh they eat whale meat,
whale blubber, walrus meat, walrus
blubber, seal meat, seal blubber, bear
meat, bear fat. There's not a single
Eskimo above the Arctic Circle that has
a Mr. Their juice man juicer eats our
gangly grown broccoli.
Their average cholesterol ranges from
250 to 350. And yet they're legendary
for not getting cardiovascular disease
until they come down to the lower 48 and
eat like us. Then when they get the
cardiovascular disease, they go back
home to die up above the Arctic Circle.
They start eating whale blubber again.
It goes away. Well, learning all that, I
felt very confident in telling my
patients, look, we're going to do
something different. My goal as a
physician is to have my patients die at
an average age of 100. I don't want my
patients down to 75.5. I want to give
them another 25 years. I want the
average lifespan for my patients to be a
hundred. And we're going to do something
different. If you want to do everything
that all the other doctors and patients
are doing, I want you to go to them
because I don't want you to lower my
average, right? We're going to do
something different. It's just real
simple. My favorite disease is
arthritis. I love arthritis. The reason
why I love arthritis is it's easy to
fix. And when you can fix something as
horrible and as debilitating, as painful
and as expensive and as miserable as
arthritis, you get kind of excited about
this concept of preventing and curing
diseases with nutrition. And so I tell
people about this arthritis thing all
the time. So let's have a quick look at
arthritis. Uh number one, 75 to 80% of
all Americans over the age of 50 get
arthritis to one degree or one type or
another. And according to the CDC, the
Center for Disease Control, 35 to 50
million baby boomers are going to get
arthritis in the next 7 to 10 years. And
there's not a single medical treatment
designed to prevent or fix it. Aspirin
certainly doesn't fix arthritis. Cause
gastric bleeding and death. Tylenol
doesn't fix arthritis. Causes 50,000
cases of kidney failure each year. 5,000
of which are so severe you need a kidney
transplant. Then there's ibuprofen,
Advil, and Alie. These things don't fix
arthritis and they cause liver disease
in two to 5% of the users including
liver cerosis even if you don't drink.
And then there's methtoresate and gold
shots. These things don't fix arthritis.
They subdue your bone marrow, so you
can't make normal platelets and white
blood cells. And then you have the
granddaddies of all the medical
treatments for arthritis. Prennazone and
cortisone, they don't fix arthritis.
They subdue your immune system, which
leaves you open to diseases far, far
more horrible than arthritis. And
prennazone and cortisone accelerate the
loss of minerals from your bones,
something you don't want when you have
osteoporosis and arthritis. Now, when
these prescription medications and
over-the-counter medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and
inflammation, the only thing left for
you medically is joint replacement
surgery. And uh I I never like to send
my patients in for joint replacement
surgery because they never work out
well. In fact, many times you're worse
off after the surgery than you were
before the surgery. The advantage my
patients have always had is that I'm a
veterinarian as well as a physician. And
so, I always used to tell my patients,
look, we have all these nutritional
formulas designed to prevent and cure
diseases in animals, including
arthritis. And so I tried adapting
nutritional arthritis formulas designed
to prevent and cure arthritis in pigeons
and turkeys, dogs, cats, sheeps, pigs,
horses, cows, lions, tigers, and bears
to human use. It was no surprise to me.
It works just as well in humans as it
does in animals because it was designed
to prevent and cure arthritis in pigs.
And I've literally seen tens of
thousands of people who've had a
regrowth of cartilage, ligaments,
tendons, connective tissue, bone
foundation, bone matrix. Doesn't matter
if they're 20, 30, 40, 50, 60, 70, 80,
90. I've seen people 97 years old regrow
cartilage and bone. Even if they had
bone to bone arthritis, if there's blood
supply to that joint and that bone, they
will regrow uh bone and cartilage. Well,
of course, Harvard Medical School goes
berserk when you say stuff like that.
Well, like you can't say those things.
The only thing left for people when they
get bone to bone arthritis is joint
replacement surgery. And I I'd agree
with him. If the only raw materials
you're using is Tylenol and aspirin and
penazone and cortisone, we've learned
over 50 years that you can't regrow
cartilage and bone using those things.
One of the basic things, of course, the
Harvard Medical School jumped on to and
they said, "This is so ridiculous that
this couldn't work." And so they took 29
patients, arthritis patients, who had
failed to respond in any way to heroic
medical treatment for arthritis over 15
to 20 years. They took them off all
their medication, wasn't working for
them anyway, lined them up for joint
replacement surgery, and they said,
"Look, for 90 days before we do the
surgery, they gave them a heaping
tablespoon full of groundup chicken
cartilage and their orange juice every
morning for 90 days." They were sort of
chuckling in their beer, saying,
"Nothing's going to happen." Well,
here's what happened. In 10 days, these
people, these 29 people had complete
relief of pain, inflammation, something
they hadn't had in 15 to 20 years. In 30
days, they could now open up a new
pickle jar that never been opened
without pain to the fingers, wrist,
elbows, and shoulders. In 90 days, 28 of
the 29 were clinically cured. Now, this
is from Harvard Medical School in the
Boston VA. That meant that they had
complete return to the range of motion.
All the pain, inflammation was gone in
their fingers and toes and hips and
knees and their neck. And certainly many
of them still had knots on their fingers
because it was only 90 days. And you'd
think they'd call me up, these
professors, you know, of medicine from
Harvard Medical School and from the
Boston VA, and say, "Look, Wallock, we
have to apologize to you. We've been
badmouthing you for 20 years, and why
don't you come up to Boston? Let's talk
about the whole thing." Here's what they
said. Quote, "After 3 months, it was
clear that the drug was beneficial."
Unquote, chicken cartilage had become a
drug in 90 days.
Now, why would that happen? Well,
because you can't patent chicken carage.
And they convinced at the US patent
office that they were using a drug to do
this study. And they actually got a use
patent on chicken cartilage. And you
too, for 3,500 bucks a month can get
Harvard Medical School's chicken cartage
in a capsule for arthritis. Of course,
cartilage has condroin sulfate in it,
glucosamine sulfate, collagen. These are
all the basic raw materials to rebuild
cartilage and bone. Raise your hand if
you know what the red warning lies for
on the dashboard of a car truck. Back
before we had dials showing temperatures
and things, they used to use the red
warning light, right? It was called the
idiot light. And when that red warning
light came on, it meant that your engine
was heating up. You didn't have enough
coolant or oil or maybe you broke a fan
belt or split a radiator hose. And a
reasonable person would would pull the
vehicle, car, or truck over the side of
the road and deal with the problem. So,
you didn't burn the engine. Even even a
Mercedes would burn up if you didn't
have enough coolant and oil and a fan
belt and a radiator hose. Then, of
course, the village idiot. That's why
they call it the village idiot light or
the idiot light. They'd be driving
along, they'd see that red warning light
come on. They say, "I don't have time to
deal with this." So, they whip out their
pliers, they cut the wire to the red
warning light, they keep on driving.
Even a Mercedes will burn up if it
doesn't have oil, cooling, a fan belt,
and a radiator hose, right? And so, you
really have to be the village idiot to
do that. Nobody in their right mind
would do that to their vehicle. How many
of you know what pain is for? Raise your
hand if you know what pain is for.
That's pretty good. Most of you know
that pain is the red warning light for
your body. When you get pain in your
foot, your ankle, your leg, your knee,
your hip, your back, your shoulders,
elbows, wrist, and fingers, your body is
saying, "Don't use those joints. Don't
use those bones. Don't use those muscles
until you fix them." It's absolutely
criminal. Absolutely criminal for a
doctor to write you prescription for a
pain reliever, an anti-inflammatory or
muscle relaxer, or any of those
combinations without rebuilding the
bones and the joints and the cartilage
at the same time. If they just give you
a pain reliever, just give you an
anti-inflammatory andor a muscle
relaxing without rebuilding the joints
and the bones at the same time, all
they're doing is cutting the wire of the
red warning light, you're going to wear
those bones and joints and cartilage out
faster and faster and faster. It's
actually a negative to be taking
painkillers and anti-inflammatories
without rebuilding the joints and the
bones at the same time. The reason why I
say no carbonated drinks and have been
doing that since 1964 is because
carbonated drinks actually will
neutralize your stomach acid and you
cannot efficiently absorb minerals,
digest protein, or absorb vitamin B12
without stomach acid. You have to have
stomach acid like battery acid. Doctors
have the criminal belief that you don't
need stomach acid. They give you all
these drugs to get rid of your stomach
acid, antacids, and they give you drugs
that stop producing stomach acid, right?
They don't want you to have stomach
acid. Absolutely criminal. You can't
digest food and absorb food without
stomach acid. I know most of you knew
that carbonated drinks neutralize
stomach acid. If you remember back 25,
50, 75 years ago when somebody would ask
their doctor say, "Look, I just ate a I
overeat. I over ate a Thanksgiving
dinner and I have heartburn and
indigestion. What do I do?" That was
before they had Zantac. They say, "Well,
take some Seven Up. Drink some ginger
ale. Drink some club soda. take take
some uh sparkling water because a
carbonation will neutralize your stomach
acid and give you some relief and it
would. Now, if you do that three times a
year, drink a carbonated drink three
times a year for Thanksgiving and
Christmas and Easter because you overeat
during those holidays, that's okay.
You're going to survive. But when you're
drinking 2, three, four, five, 6, 8, 10
carbonated drinks a day, you're not
going to survive because over the long
haul, you will not be able to absorb the
nutrients. You're going to get some
horrible combination of terrible
diseases. This came out June of 2000 and
this is a Harvard study on 460 junior
high school girls in nth and tth grade.
And what they found out was that those
junior high school girls who drank one
non-colacarbonated drink every day, they
increase their risk of fractures and
osteoporosis as a teenager by 300%. They
found out that if they drank one
carbonated cola drink, a cola carbonated
drink every day, they increase the risk
of fractures and osteoporosis as a
teenager by 500%.
Now, do you think that this is more
dangerous for teenagers or adults? It's
much more dangerous for adults because
you only have 25% bone matrix and you're
very, very slow to recover where
teenagers have 40% bone matrix and they
can recover in a week's time. We learned
in 1957 from a turkey study uh where
they took 250,000 turkeys and they put
them on a complete turkey pellet trying
to get them to finish for market within
a few days or a week or so of each
other. And in the first 13 weeks, fully
half of them, 125,000 of them died.
Farmers were out there every morning.
They picked them up every morning by the
bushel basket fulls, took them to the
state diagnostic lab to see what they
died from. When they opened them up,
every one of them had died of a ruptured
aortic aneurysm. And one of the clever
pathologists says that's got to be due
to a copper deficiency because copper is
required to manufacture the elastic
fibers of arteries and skin and other
tissues. And the mechanism of an
aneurysm is identical to the mechanism
of a balloon on a weakened wall of a
tire. You know when you hit a chuck hole
with your tire and you break the cords,
the internal pressure blows a balloon.
you overload that tire with weight or
heat it up on a highway, it blows out.
Same way with an aneurysm. When you have
a copper deficiency, you get a breakdown
of the elastic fibers uh in that artery,
the internal pressure, even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon in that
artery. And a balloon in an artery is
called an aneurysm. And of course, if
it's in a strategic place like the
brain, cored artery, the coronary
arteries, the large arteries, the aorta,
pulmonary artery, renal arteries, they
blow out, you die suddenly, uh just like
you've been shot. Well, they got excited
about this. They doubled the amount of
uh copper in these um pellets. The next
year they tried to raise 500,000 turkeys
and they did not lose a single one from
a ruptured aneurysm. They went from a
50% loss to a 0% loss just by adding a
little bit of copper to those pellets.
So they said, "Well, maybe the same
thing is true for humans." And in 19 uh
58 they started looking at copper
deficiency in various species of animals
and humans. And here's what they found
out. The very first symptom of copper
deficiency is white, gray, and silver
hair. Copper is required as a co-actor
to manufacture hair pigment. It doesn't
matter if it's blonde, red, brown, or
black hair. And I see a lot of copper
deficiency in this room. I can almost
tell you which people, men and women,
who have colored their hair, get pretty
good at that being a physician. And you
don't want to be like a medical doctor
and just treat the symptoms. If you're
just coloring your hair, you're treating
the symptoms. You need to do the basic
thing of take some colloidal copper. And
if you don't, uh, what's going to happen
is, uh, you get a breakdown of the
elastic fibers in your skin and you
start getting crows feet around the
corners of your eyes and your mouth.
Parts of your anatomy begin to sag. And
you know you're in trouble when your
doctor tells you, "Look, I've got a golf
buddy down the hall who's a plastic
surgeon. For $10,000 will make you look
20 years younger." But you don't need a
facelift, a booby lift, a tummy tuck, or
a derriè lift. All you need is some
copper and everything will come back up
just like you have a hydraulic jack
under it. It'll just come right back up.
Those elastic fibers tighten right up.
People say, "Francine, did you get a
facelift? You look great. You look like
you're 20 years younger." Now, if you
don't take some action at that point,
the next thing that happens is you get a
breakdown of the elastic fibers and the
large veins of your legs and you get
varicose veins. You don't take action at
that point. You get a breakdown of the
elastic fibers and large veins of your
exhaust pipe and you get hemorrhoids. So
if you have hemorrhoids, varicose veins,
things that sag, wrinkles, white, gray
or silver hair, the odds are you have
aneurisms developing in you somewhere
and you don't want to, of course, die
suddenly of a ruptured aneurysm when
your body's been warning you for 10, 20,
30 years. Just remember, people don't
die suddenly of an aneurysm. It may be
you drop and die. Think about old Albert
Einstein. He died of a ruptured aortic
aneurysm at 68 years of age. What color
was his hair? He was famous for wild
white hair, wasn't he? Now, you'd like
to think that people who win the Nobel
Prize in medicine would at least live to
be 75.5. But they lived to be 58 just
like other doctors. And of course,
that's because they are trained and they
believe and they practice. You can get
everything you need from your four food
groups. Doesn't matter if they win the
Nobel Prize or not. This guy here, Dr.
George Kohler, was the youngest person
ever to win the Nobel Prize in medicine
in history. 37 years old, wins the Nobel
Prize in medicine. and he won the Nobel
Prize in medicine for studying monoconal
antibodies, which are antibodies trained
to attack cancer cells. And if they ever
get this really working, it'll be great
because they won't have to use
chemotherapy anymore, which kills more
people than it saves. 11 years after
winning the Nobel Prize in medicine, Dr.
George Kohler, now 48, drops dead of a
cardiamopathy heart attack because he
believed you can get everything you need
from your four food groups. Didn't take
any selenium, died of a cardiamopathy
heart attack. Now, I have to tell you
why athletes are early warning system.
Couch potatoes by definition are people
who go to extraordinary efforts not to
sweat. Right? They make every human
effort not to sweat. They're changing
the TV channels. Honey, bring in the
popcorn. I'm changing the channels. Son,
bring me the TV guide. I'm changing the
channels. By contrast, athletes have the
attitude, no pain, no gain. And they're
out there sweating and working away,
power training, strength training,
running, and they sweat. Athletes, no
matter age, they sweat more in five
years than couch potatoes do in 70
years. And when you sweat, you don't
just sweat out potassium and Gatorade.
You sweat out all 60 essential minerals.
If you sweat out all of your selenium
and don't replace it by supplementation,
you're at high risk of getting a
cardiammyopathy heart attack. You sweat
out all of your copper and don't replace
it by supplementation, you're at high
risk of developing an aneurysm and dying
and suddenly have a ruptured aneurysm.
You sweat out all of your chromium and
venadium and don't replace it by
supplementation, you're at high risk of
getting diabetes. And if you sweat out
all of your calcium and magnesium and
boron and zinc and sulfur and other
minerals are required for cartilage,
ligaments, tendons, connective tissue,
bone, you're going to get a joint and
bone injury. What is the biggest single
cause of an athletes career being ended
early? Joint and bone problems, right?
And that's because they sweat out all
the basic minerals that they need to
maintain those parts of their body and
they don't supplement with them because
doctors tell them that they can get
everything they need their four food
groups. Well, what are the early warning
systems for mineral deficiencies? We
already told you about white, gray, or
silver hair for a copper deficiency.
Liver spots or age spots in the back of
your hand, side of your face or neck.
These things are caused by a selenium
deficiency. And you know again about
selenium deficiency. Then of course you
have toe cramps, leg cramps, you can
have hypertension. These things are all
caused by a deficiency of calcium. And
if you're an athlete at age 25 or 15 and
you get a leg cramp that's a calcium
deficiency, your body's telling you if
you don't stop drinking those Pepsis and
start supplementing with some calcium,
by the time you're 40, 50, 60 years old,
you're going to have arthritis and
osteoporosis. But most people say, "Wow,
I got to get this high prize trainer. I
need somebody who can give me massage
therapy because I have a cramp." And
they don't go and take their
supplements. 85% of the total mineral in
your body is a calcium. There's 147
different diseases you can get from a
calcium deficiency. We're just going to
quickly go over the top 10 when it comes
to number of people affected and the
amount of money involved. Let's look at
osteoporosis. The number 10 killer of
adults in the United States. Remember,
75% of the those over age 65 who
fracture a hip or major leg bone don't
live 90 days. Also, it's the most
horrible disease when it comes to human
misery and dollars expended.
Osteoporosis. Think of the special vans
and the lift gates and the ramps and the
elevators, the special plumbing and
homes and and public buildings, special
parking places, wheelchairs and walkers
and canes. Think of the beds and the
chairs that are little electric motors
to lift you up when you can't stand up
by yourself. Physical therapists, joint
replacement surgeries, pharmaceuticals,
doctor's visits. We're talking billions
and billions of dollars for nothing more
than a calcium deficiency disease. Now,
as horrible as a disease as osteoporosis
is in human beings, we don't have
osteoporosis in animals because we don't
have Blue Cross Blue Shield, major
medical hospitalization, Medicare, and
Medicaid to pay for nonsensical surgical
treatments for mineral deficiency. We've
learned that by putting animals who are
weaned off their mother's milk on
calcium as soon as they're weaned, they
won't get arthritis, osteoporosis. It's
amazing how that works. Receding gums.
Dentist and dental hygienists will tell
you to floss and brush after every meal.
If you believe that works, I have some
oceanfront property in Montana to sell
you. If you have receding gums,
perodontitis, gingivitis, porrhea, loose
teeth, bridges, and plates, you actually
have osteoporosis of the facial bones
and the jawbones. We don't get receding
gums in animals, even though they don't
floss or brush. That's because we've
taken care of the osteoporosis problem
in animals. Arthritis. 85% of all
arthritis is called wear and tear
arthritis. Osteoarthritis, degenerative
arthritis, ankylosing spondylitis. These
things are nothing more than
osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones. Hypertension, high blood
pressure, as you've learned, has nothing
to do with salt or salt restriction. 85%
of hypertension not related to kidney
disease which is most of them not
related to kidney disease is in fact a
calcium deficiency. Insomnia is not a
deficiency of sleeping pills calcium or
barbituates. It's a deficiency of
calcium. Kidney stones, bone spurs, heel
spurs and calcium deposits. Again the
medical profession has a malignant dumb
belief that these things are due to too
much calcium in your diet. Tell you to
give up calcium when in fact you only
get kidney stones, bone spurs, heel
spurs and calcium deposits when you have
raging osteoporosis. You actually need
more calcium, more magnesium, not less.
Cramps and twitches. Raise your hand.
How many of you ever had a toe cramp,
foot cramp, leg cramp in your life?
Sure. That's the first symptom of a
calcium deficiency that most people
recognize. So, if you've ever had that,
sometime in your life, you've had a
calcium deficiency. Then you have PMS.
The University of California, San Diego
came out and said that 85% of the
emotional and physical stuff of PMS can
be relieved, eliminated, and cured. They
use the cure word by taking three times
the RDA of calcium. Low back pain has
nothing to do with disc problems. I know
you've heard of people, maybe even
yourself, have had a disc surgery for
back pain. And after the surgery, you
still had the pain, maybe even worse
because back pain is not caused by disc
problems. If you have a disc problem,
you can have numbness and tingling,
maybe even paralysis if it's very
severe, but disc problems do not cause
pain. We learned in 1957 in animals that
we could prevent and cure adult onset
diabetes with two trace minerals,
chromium and venadium. In 1985, the
medical school at the University of
Vancouver, British Columbia up in Canada
came out and said that trace mineral
venadium alone could replace insulin and
adult onset diabetics. Science diet dog
food has 40 minerals in it. Always has
chromium, venadium, lithium, and
selenium. Rollston pina laboratory rat
pellets has 28 minerals. Always contains
chromium, venadium, lithium, and
selenium. I'll give anybody in this room
a crisp new $100 bill if you can find me
a human infant formula off the shelf of
a grocery store that has more than 12
minerals in it. None of them contain
chromium, venadium or lithium. Only one
probi well two actually prozzo and
infamilil I believe has 12 because they
put in the um selenium. The rest of them
don't. They have 11, 10, nine or eight
minerals. Our dogs get 40 minerals. Our
rats get 28 and our kids get 12 or less.
You don't have to be a research
scientist to realize why our kids are
now getting all these horrible diseases
that used to occur in people in their
60s, 70s, and 80s. all these diseases
that that um doctors are wondering how
is this genetic? These kids shouldn't
have this till they're 60. Well, that's
because they couldn't get it out of
their little can of stuff. If it's not
in the can, they don't get it. Again, we
need nutrients, 16 minerals, 16
vitamins, 12 essential amino acids,
three essential fatty acids. And
fortunately, over the thousands of years
that human beings have been around, we
haven't had to think much about this
because our food plants, our grains,
vegetables, fruits, and nuts take carbon
dioxide out of the air and manufacture
long carbon chains, many of which are
vitamins, amino acids, and fatty acids.
And this is where this medical kaka came
from that you can get everything you
need from your four food groups because
they say, "Well, plants, grains, fruits,
vegetables, and nuts can manufacture
vitamins, amino acids, and fatty acids."
But we've tried this experiment for 200
years. Americans have eaten better than
anybody else in the world. We've had the
best quality food in the world over
anybody else. And yet we only live to be
75.5. We don't set any health or
longevity records. So if you want to
live to be over 100, can't get it from
eating your four food groups. You can
live to be 75.5. You may live 10 years
older, 10 years younger, but on the
average 75.5. So if you want to live to
be over 100, you do have to supplement
with vitamins, amino acids, and fatty
acids. There's three types of minerals
you have to concern yourself with. First
of all, there's metallic minerals. These
are things like oyster shell, eggshell,
limestone,
coral calcium, seabed minerals, clays of
various types, tums is a popular one
with doctors, lactates, gluconates,
citrates, oxides, sulfates, carbonates.
These are nothing but groundup rocks.
We're not designed to eat ground up
rocks. Nobody can show you we're humans
or animals are designed to eat ground up
rocks. We are designed to get our
minerals by eating plants, grains,
vegetables, fruits, and nuts. And as a
result, plant derived minerals are
absorbable, more absorbable than
chelated, more absorbable than the
elemental or metallic minerals. Plant
derived minerals are liquid. They're
very small particle size. They're 7,000
times smaller than red blood cell. This
is the way they're stored in your cells
and are moved around in plant vascular
systems and human vascular systems in
the um liquid plant derived form.
They're negatively charged. I don't know
all of the physics and the chemistry is
one of the basic features of a colloidal
mineral that's negatively charged. These
three factors together give you
absorbability. Now the way it's supposed
to be is our food plants are grains,
vegetables, fruits and nuts take the
elemental or metallic minerals out of
the soil, convert them to minerals for
their own use, for their own metabolism
and biochemistry and then animals and
people eat these plants that are
enriched with minerals. That's how we're
designed to get our minerals.
Unfortunately, we have several problems
here. For 100 years, we've used a simple
fertilizer known as NPK. We put in three
nutrients into the soil when we need 60
minerals. We put those three nutrients
in the soil for maximum yields per ton
and bushel per acre. Uh then of course
we have to understand that plants cannot
manufacture minerals. If they're not in
the soil, they're not in the plants.
Plants only have minerals in them if
they're in the soil. Plants cannot
manufacture minerals. Over 90 years at
least, we've been deficient in our soils
in America. And as a result, our food is
deficient. And as a result, the crops,
the grains, fruits, vegetables, and nuts
that are grown there are mineral
deficient. And as a result, the animals
and people who eat these mineral
deficient crops get mineral deficiency
diseases. And the only way to prevent
and cure them is with mineral
supplements.
[Applause]
Yes, I'm a construction worker and um I
hurt my back. He said that my uh
cartilage damage is permanent. Is there
anything that can be done?
Well, first of all, how old are you? I'm
28 years old.
And what do you normally take for fluid
replacement when you're working out in
construction? What do you drink during
the day?
Uh, water, Gatorade.
You don't drink any soft drinks?
Uh, yes, I do.
Okay. Cuz normally construction workers
drink a couple of liters of Pepsi a day,
right?
Yeah, I could probably put down a liter
per.
And did you take any vitamins or
minerals while you were working in
construction?
Um, just recently started.
When you were in construction, prior to
the back problems?
Yeah. A lot of con construction workers
will tell me, "Well, doc, if it ain't in
the Pepsi, I don't get it." Right? And
so, uh, you're a perfect candidate for
the pig or thrus formula plus the EFA.
You need all 90 essential nutrients and
give up the bad things. Give up the soft
drinks and the iced tea and the
lemonades and and give up the fried
foods and the margarine. And uh I can
just tell you with your age uh you can
honestly expect to see some uh really
recognizable results in a very very
short time, 60 to 90 days. And it
doesn't matter what the doctor said. If
you do the right things, get rid of the
bad stuff, take all 90 essential
nutrients, uh making sure you get that
collagen and the glucosamine sulfate and
the condrit sulfate, you will repair
your vertebrae, you will repair the
cartilage, and you will repair the disc.
Dr. Well, it just seems like every week
I pick up a newspaper and I see about
our young athletes having problems with
their bodies falling apart. What can we
give our athletes and our children so
that they can be healthy and have long
lives that we want as well?
It's a great question because most
people believe that exercise is good for
you and it was always a great question.
You know, is exercise good for you? Is
it necessary for health and longevity?
And when you inspect this question, uh,
you have to look at professional
athletes who, uh, spend most of their
teenage years and going through
university and the semi-pros and the
pros, uh, training and practicing and
doing their events. And, and if exercise
was the factor in living a long
healthful life, athletes should live
longer than couch potatoes. But when you
look at this critically, couch potatoes
in America lived to be 75.5. And the
average athlete, depending on the sport
and their level of competence, live to
be 62 to 68, far short of what a couch
potato lives to be. And of course,
athletes suffer from a great many joint
diseases and bone injuries and tendons
and ligaments, back, necks, shoulders,
ankles, knees, and hips and have to
suffer through an enormous amount of
surgeries to deal with this. And
athletes develop some 800 different
diseases. And what is it? Why is it that
athletes don't fare as well as the couch
potato? Well, it's simply because
athletes sweat more in 5 years than
couch potatoes do in 75 years. And when
you sweat, you're not just sweating out
Gatorade. You're sweating out all 60
essential minerals. And they're called
essential minerals because if they're
missing for any length of time, you get
some horrible degenerative disease, many
of which are are life-threatening. So,
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
to figure out who's more likely to be
debilitated or even die of these these
life-threatening diseases. an athlete
who sweats out quarts of sweat during an
event or training or practice or a couch
potato who's laying on a couch in an air
conditioned dense switching the channels
yelling, "Honey, bring in the popcorn.
I'm changing the channels." And this is
very serious because the center for
disease control says that as many as a
100,000 young athletes under the age of
30, a 100,000 each year die suddenly
during an event or training or exercise
or immediately after an event from
cardiamopathy heart disease and ruptured
aneurysm. And we know that cardiamopathy
heart disease is due to a selenium
deficiency and ruptured aneurysms is due
to a copper deficiency. So you can begin
to put two and two together. Why does a
10-year-old die of a ruptured aneurysm?
Well, he sweat out all of his copper and
you can't get copper from curly French
fries and Pepsis. It just doesn't work.
Dr. Wallik, what about arthritis?
Well, arthritis is my favorite disease
because it's easy to fix. Uh, it's one
of the great myths that the medical
profession perpetuates is that you can't
build bone mass after the age of 50, 60,
70 years of age. You can only slow down
the loss. And the reason why they say
that is because they try to rebuild bone
mass using plain calcium, whether it's
Tums or calcium citrate or carbonate or
gluconate or or lactate. And your body
will not retain much or any of the
calcium you supplement with in your
bones without first building new bone
matrix. You have to have new bone
matrix. This is this rubbery collagen
material that looks like tendon or skin.
And that makes up 25 to 40% of our bone
weight. 40% when you're a child and 25%
when you're an adult. And so it's
absolutely essential if you want to deal
with the wear and tear arthritis,
osteoarthritis, degenerative arthritis,
ankylosing spondylitis effectively, you
have to take all 90 essential nutrients.
And the best way to do that is with Dr.
Wallik's pig arthritis formula.
Remember, I'm a veterinarian as well as
a physician. And we learned a long time
ago, maybe a hundred years ago in
veterinary medicine that we could
actually prevent and reverse, maybe even
use the cure word in animals arthritis
simply by giving the animal the raw
material to develop properly and to
maintain and repair the joints. And so
using this information that we developed
in animals, if you use the same concept
for human beings, I have literally seen
tens of thousands of people over the
years who had bone to bone arthritis.
They had osteoarthritis, they have
degenerative arthritis, ankalloing
spondylitis, which are basically a joint
form of osteoporosis. It's osteoporosis
the joint ends of the bones. And they've
tried all kinds of medication. And of
course, if you take medication, if you
take a painkiller, if you take an
anti-inflammatory for arthritis,
essentially all you're doing is cutting
the wire, the red warning light. Pain in
a joint says, "Don't use me until you
fix me." And by taking a painkiller, by
taking a anti-inflammatory, which will
reduce pain, you're allowing that joint
to be used even though it would have
been painful without the drug. And so,
you're wearing that joint out faster and
faster and faster. And to me, it's
criminally negligent for someone to be
prescribed a painkiller or an
anti-inflammatory for joint disease
without repairing the joint at the same
time. And this is where the pigthus
formula really shines and works just
like a charm in human beings.
So, does the same apply for bone spurs?
Absolutely. Bone spurs are a
manifestation of osteoporosis. A person
will get bone spurs and calcium deposits
when you have osteoporosis. Just the
opposite of what a doctor will tell you.
And you need more calcium, more
magnesium. You need the bone matrix. You
need the collagen, the glucosamine
sulfate, the chondrite and sulfate. And
those bone spurs and the calcium
deposits will actually rearchitecture
back down to a normal bone. Takes a
little while. Takes four to 6 months to
pull that off, but you can do it on a
regular basis. Absolutely.
Cancer seems to be striking everywhere
in our population these days. What do we
have that we can help people that are
facing the challenge of cancer? Well,
it's a great question. And uh back at
the turn of the century 1895 1900 one
out of 10 Americans develop cancer.
Right now it's three out of five and by
the year 20150 it's projected two out of
three people are going to develop cancer
in America. The onset of cancer appears
to be directly related to the amount of
of carcinogens.
These are toxic waste either from
agriculture or from the industrial waste
that we find in our air and our food and
our water and in the dust around us. And
the lack of the ability to defend
against these these carcinogens. And the
most common defense mechanism that we
have, the one that we have access to in
a very economical way are the
antioxidants like selenium, like the
grape seed extract, like the green tea.
You're looking at vitamin E, vitamin C,
beta carotene, and avoiding fried foods
and margarine and and things that we
have control of, eating as much
organically grown food as possible. And
according to the medical school at the
University of Arizona, and this came out
in JAMAMA, the Journal of the American
Medical Association, December 25th,
1996, I mean, we're talking about a
great Christmas gift to the American
people. They did a wonderful study, 10
years. It was a double blind study, 1300
people. They gave the study group 250
micrograms, which is one quarter of 1
milligram. And we're talking an
itsybitsy amount of selenium. They just
use selenium alone. Didn't change
anything else. And by giving these
people 250 micrograms 1/4 of a milligram
of the trace mineral selenium they were
able to reduce the risk of esophageal
cancer by 71% prostate cancer by 69%
greater than 2/3 colon and rectal cancer
by 64% almost 2/3 lung cancer was
reduced by 48% whether you smoked or not
and in a parallel study from the
University of California San Diego 250
micrograms one quarter of 1 milligram of
selenium the trace selenium reduce the
risk of breast cancer by 50 to 80%. And
the same study showed that if you
already have cancer, if you take 250
micrograms of selenium every day, uh you
will in fact double the natural history
life expectancy of a particular type of
cancer. For instance, lung cancer the
natural history is about a year. Brain
cancer is less than a year. Uh uterine,
ovarian, colon, breast cancer is 2 to 5
years. Prostate cancer is 5 to 8 years.
Well, just by taking 250 micrograms of
the trace mineral selenium every day,
one quarter of 1 milligram according to
the University of of Arizona's medical
school, uh you can double that life
expectancy just by doing that one thing.
And so if you take the other
antioxidants and give up margins and
fried foods and sugar and caffeine and
avoid as many of the agricultural waste
and the toxic waste from the industry
that you can, you will be able to avoid
an enormous amount of cancer. And if you
already have cancer, doing other things
such as taking the um antioxidants and
getting on macrobiotic diets and and so
forth, you can add many healthful years
to your life, you can certainly have a
better quality of life. And many people
uh will extend their lives in a in a
great way, 10, 20, 30, 40 years. And
obviously, there's no way you can look
in somebody's eyes and say, "You're the
one that's going to live 50 years." And
so people just have to do all the right
things and they're going to get the best
that can be gotten from nutrition and
the the supplements.
Dr. Warick, I've been a diabetic for
about 30 years. What can what kind of
mineral should I take to help me?
Okay. Well, first of all, are you an
adult onset type 2 diabetic or a
juvenile onset type 1 diabetic?
Juvenile onset type 1. you are in
insulin dependent because the definition
of a juvenile onset type 1 diabetic is
that you do not make any insulin and so
you will never be able to wean off of
insulin. You will always have to take
some insulin. But uh there are two trace
minerals chromium and venadium that will
make the insulin that you supplement
yourself with very efficient. And most
people who are juvenile onset type 1
diabetics are able to reduce the amount
of insulin they require to stabilize
their blood sugar uh by supplementing
with the chromium and venadium. Normally
a person learns how to adjust their
insulin by taking their blood sugar once
or twice or three times a day. And so
you're taught how to adjust your insulin
intake. And just by following what
you've been taught uh as you supplement
with this plant derived colloidal and
the chelated chromium and venadium, you
will be able to get down to a new dosage
of your insulin. And the value of taking
the whole pig arthritis formula is that
there's nothing worse than paying
attention to your blood sugar levels,
your insulin intake, and then dying of a
ruptured aneurysm because you didn't
supplement with copper or developing
cancer because you didn't supplement
with selenium. So it's very important
even though you're a diabetic and that
is your primary immediate concern still
over the long haul uh being a
healthconscious person just out of
necessity uh you're going to have to
supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients and uh the odds are even
though you're a juvenile onset type 1
diabetic you have every honest
expectation of living to be 100 symptom
free if you do everything right.
Yes. My question is on Alzheimer's. Why
is it more prevalent today that than it
was 15 20 years ago?
Well, actually Alzheimer's disease was a
disease that did not exist 40 years ago.
Uh Alzheimer's disease even by another
name could not be found in any medical
dictionary or textbook or taught in any
medical curriculum. It only became an
entity in the medical literature in
1979. And today it's apparently the
number four killer of adults in the
United States over the age of 65 behind
cardiovascular disease, cancer,
diabetes, and then comes Alzheimer's
disease. And it's appears uh to me with
no doubt that it's due to what I call a
physiciancaused disease because doctors
have have encouraged people in fact
demanded that people give up saturated
fat and cholesterol and move towards a
cholesterol restricted or even a
cholesterol-free diet to get their blood
cholesterol down below 200. And they
have created no less than 25 of these
cholesterol deficiency diseases. And to
me Alzheimer's disease is one of the big
ones. 75% of our brain weight is pure
cholesterol. It's called myelin. It's
this fatty stuff that insulates each
nerve fiber, the brain and spinal cord.
And we can only make about 10% of our
daily need of cholesterol. The other 90%
must come from the diet. And if a person
is very very good at giving up chicken
skin and red meat and dairy and eggs
like a doctor would have them do, after
about six or eight or 10 years, they're
not going to be able to keep up with the
maintenance and repair needs of the
cholesterol for the myelin in the brain
and spinal cord. And so you can just
expect that the person's going to
develop one or more of these 25
physician caused diseases including
acquired seizure disorders and
Alzheimer's disease. Now the best way to
avoid Alzheimer's disease is to eat a
couple of eggs every morning for
breakfast, not cooked in margin or
fried. Uh you want to consume as much as
72 ounces of red meat every month. I
know that sounds like a lot, but it's
just a quarter pounder a day. And you
want to supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients. And when you get to the the
vitamin E level, you want to have at
least 2,000 international units of
vitamin E and you want 500 micrograms of
selenium. And if you do that, even if
you already have Alzheimer's disease,
you can expect to have a significant
amount of return of memory. Great study
done by the University of California,
San Diego, and the Sulk Institute that
says by taking 2,000 international units
of vitamin E alone, even if you have
advanced Alzheimer's disease, you can
get a significant amount of of memory
return. I've remodeled homes for
families. You notice these little
children bouncing off of walls and what
they get for breakfast and a snack after
breakfast and then lunch again. Normally
has sugar in it. Is there any uh
correlation here with ADD?
Absolutely. Back at the turn of the
century, 1895 to 1900, Americans were
eating a half a pound of sugar per
person per year. Today it's 150 lbs of
sugar per person per year. And somebody
out there is eating 300 pounds because I
don't eat any. And I can tell you that
there's a direct correlation between the
increase in ADD, ADHD, depression, manic
depression, bipolar disease, and the
increased consumption of sugar. And if
you look at it, there's 5 million
American children, school age children
who are on rolin and Prozac and other
anti-depressants in school. 5 million
drugged American kids in in preschool
and elementary school simply because
these kids are sensitive to sugar like
many people are sensitive to alcohol. Uh
there's good alcoholics who just kind of
go to sleep when they have a couple of
drinks. Uh there's the people who get
boisterous and sing loud Irish songs
when they take a couple of drinks. And
there are some people who get violent
and and very angry and become dangerous
to themselves and other people. Uh child
abuse, spouse abuse, they abuse their
neighbors. Road rage is another way of
looking at this. Uh life-threatening
situations. Uh people actually will gain
criminal behavior sometimes because
alcohol acts like a drug in them. Same
way with sugar. Some people when they
take in sugar, they have low blood sugar
and they just get drowsy and fall
asleep. Some people when they take in
sugar, they get hyperactive and
boisterous and and uh actually um ADD,
ADHD. And then there's some people when
they take in sugar again will have road
rage. uh they're very very um uh
aggressive and reactive and could be
dangerous to themselves and their
families and other people in the
community. And to me, it's criminal for
Coca-Cola machines and and candy
machines in school and then wonder why
kids beat up on each other or shoot each
other. Well, in addition to getting all
the sugar out of their life from sugar
frosted flakes and Pepsis and Reese's
peanut butter cups and candy and and
Pop-Tarts and syrup on their AOS, uh
they have to supplement with all 90
essential nutrients. even little kids
from the moment they're born to develop
properly. This includes their emotions
and repair and maintain themselves and
especially lithium, chromium and
venadium. And there's an enormous amount
of research in human beings which show
that lithium deficiency results in
hyperactivity, ADD, ADHD, depression,
manic depression and criminal behavior.
And so they have to do both and you can
avoid all this. Uh it's amazing just
within days they will be perfectly
normal little kids.
My next question is, "My husband and I
are thinking about starting a family and
we want to know the nutritional way to
go."
Okay, that's a great question. People
always ask me when when do children need
to start taking vitamins and minerals.
And the answer is when there's still an
egg is when you want to start them. So,
uh, we've learned in the animal
industry, and remember I'm a
veterinarian as well as a physician,
we've learned in the animal industry,
that we could prevent as much as 98% of
all birth defects, even ones that are
thought to be genetic in humans, simply
by giving the females, especially the
females, all known essential nutrients
for that species, 6 months prior to
conception. build up that female
animal's body and stores of these
essential nutrients so that the embryo
implants in the uterine wall and
develops in an environment that has
optimal amounts guaranteed optimal
amounts of all the nutrients and you
will almost eliminate the possibility of
a congenital birth defect related to a
mineral or vitamin or amino acid or
essential fatty acid deficiency. To give
you some idea of how successful this is,
according to the University of
California, San Francisco, right now in
America, one out of every 33 human
babies in America are born with some
physical or emotional or mental birth
defect. One out of 33. In animals, it's
only one out of 500,000 if they're fed
these commercial diets that have all the
known nutrients in them. And so it's
just very very easy to understand well
if we supplement young women and men who
are in the childbearing years with these
nutrients that we'll be able to
eliminate totally eliminate cleft
pallets, cleft lips, spinobipida, eye
defects, heart defects, hernas of
various types, club feet, no feet, web
fingers and toes, no fingers and toes,
uh muscular distrophe, down syndrome,
cerebral paly, cystic fibrosis, these
are all preventable. with proper
preconception nutrition. So the earlier
that a couple who wants to uh have
normal healthy children and have a
wonderful uncomplicated pregnancy, the
earlier you can get on all 90 essential
nutrients prior to conception, the
better off everybody is.
Hello Dr. Wallik. The women in my family
are plagued with hay fever and asthma
and allergies and I don't want to join
those ranks. Is there a better way?
Absolutely. Uh let's start with asthma.
It's the easiest one to deal with.
Asthma is actually a deficiency of three
nutrients, magnesium, manganesees, and
the essential fatty acids. And by taking
the pig thrus formula twice a day,
you're going to get the optimal amounts
of the plant derived colloidal and the
chilated magnesium and manganesees. And
then by taking the minimum daily
requirement, the 9 g of the essential
fatty acids. And those three nutrients
together, the magnesium, manganesees,
and the essential fatty acids will allow
you to produce what's called
prostaglandins. Prostaglandins are
little short-lived hormones that last in
your bloodstream 30 seconds, 60 seconds,
and your body's continuously making them
kind of rapid fire. And when you don't
have those three nutrients, you cannot
make the proper prostaglandins to keep
your bronchi and your trachea open. And
that's when you develop asthma. And it
it's very common when people take all 90
essential nutrients, including the
magnesium and manganesees and the
essential fatty acids. within weeks or
months, the tightness, this constant
tightness in their chest is
significantly reduced or maybe even
totally relieved. The frequency and the
severity of their asthma attacks is
reduced. I would certainly still keep an
inhaler available until, you know, in
case you have some unexpected emergency.
Kind of like wearing your seat belt even
though you're on a smooth flight and you
you're not going to uh anticipate sudden
turbulence. You need to be prepared for
emergencies, but um have very honest
expectation of doing very well. Then as
far as inhalent allergies from dust and
pollins and uh seasonal ones from dust
and pollins and maybe constant ones from
danders and cats and dogs and chickens
and feathers and your pillows, that kind
of thing. Maybe even chemicals that come
out of rugs and for mica and new cars
like formaldahhide and other chemicals.
Um you want to get your immune system
working optimally so it can protect you
from these things because most people
are able to tolerate them. And what
happens is when your immune system
doesn't have enough nutrition to
function optimally, uh you become a
victim of these things assaulting you
all the time. And so what you want to do
is number one take all 90 essential
nutrients. So your immune system which
includes your liver and your spleen,
your tonsils and your appendix, your
thymus, uh your um white blood cells
which include the neutrfils and the
lymphosytes and the killer tea cells and
so forth. Also you have eosinaphils and
basophils. You have neutrfils. All of
these white blood cells. You have
albumans and globbulins which are the
the immune proteins. You have antibodies
themselves. You have your digestive
system, your skin, your tears, the mucus
in your body. All of that requires 90
essential nutrients to produce this
immune system which is not just your
killer tea cells. Uh it it includes all
of these tissues and and cells and
organs of your body. Uh, also if you
have these types of problems, you want
to get some of these HEPA filters uh at
your workplace in your home when you
sleep. You can get the ones that you
plug in your car. You want to eat as
much organically grown food as possible.
You want to drink filtered water. You
want to get as much chemicals out of
your diet as possible and reduce this
pressure on your immune system. If you
have food allergies, you want to have a
five-day rotation diet. You want to take
the enzyme which has the pepsin and the
betane hydrochloride which will help a
person digest the proteins down into
single amino acid. And it's the proteins
and the allergens such as danders and
foods and pollins and dust that cause
the the allergies and even can initiate
an attack of asthma.
Thank you.
You're very welcome.
Is it possible that you can take too
much? Well, it's a great question and
because people are concerned about
overdosing with vitamins and minerals,
the general answer is that if you look
at the medical profession, according to
the center for disease control, Harvard
Medical School, the US News and World
Report, Ralph Nater, Sydney Wolf, Rand
Corporation, and many many other
wellrespected institutions. They say
that doctors kill 150,000 to 300,000
Americans each year in hospitals alone
as a result of medical negligence.
Doctors injure 1.3 million Americans
each year in hospitals alone as a result
of medical negligence. And doctors
infect 2 million Americans alone in
hospitals as a result of medical
negligence for a total of three and a
half million casualties inflicted on the
American public each year in hospitals
just as as a result of medical
negligence. On the other side of this
picture, there's not a single person
who's overdosed in vitamins and minerals
and trace minerals to the point where
they have to be hospitalized or anything
bad happened. And so when you compare
the safety of vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals compared with standard
medical procedures, it's enormously
safe. And that's why I'm so excited
about nutrition and the pigthus formula
and the plant derived colloidal
minerals. And that's the direction I'd
go.
Dr. Wallik, my 16-year-old daughter has
been diagnosed with fibromyalgia. What
can you do for her?
Well, that's actually an easy one. We
eliminated fibromyalgia in animals in
1957.
And in sheep, it was called stiff lamb
disease. and also in sheep and calves
and fos or baby horses and chickens and
turkeys and any any other animal that
was raised for meat. Uh the disease is
uh caused by a deficiency of three
nutrients. The trace mineral selenium,
vitamin E and the sulfur bearing amino
acid methionine. And there's two things
you have to do to deal with
fibromyalgia. Number one, eliminate the
free radicals and the trans fatty acids
that actually initiate damage to the
muscle and causes scarring of the muscle
tissue which is very painful even normal
muscle movement. And you can understand
why they call it stiff lamb disease. If
you have fibromyalgia,
first of all, you eliminate fried foods
such as fried potatoes, which are, you
know, teenagers live on fried potatoes,
right? So have to eliminate fried
potatoes, fried chicken, fish, shrimp,
fried eggs, uh, tempura, stir fry,
anything fried, all margarine, salad
dressings with oils in them have to be
eliminated. And then again the piger
thris form was perfect because it has
optimal amounts of the trace mineral
selenium in both the plant derived
colloidal and the chelated form. It has
optimal amounts of vitamin E and the
sulfur bearing amino acid methane and it
just works like a charm very quickly
within weeks or months they feel and
they can recognize some benefit and many
people will get significant benefit very
quickly.
Dr. Wick are baby formulas enough for
our babies when they're born?
Unfortunately not. Uh our our formulas
that we give to dogs, whether you know
it's kind of like um science diet dog
food are the puppy or kitten milk
replacers for puppies and kittens you're
going to raise by hand have 40 minerals
in them including the uh minerals um
lithium, chromium, venadium, and
selenium. Write laboratory rat pellets
contain 28 minerals including lithium,
chromium, venadium, and selenium.
There's not a single human milk replacer
on the market on a off the shelf of a
grocery store that has more than 12
minerals. None of them contain lithium,
chromium, venadium, and only two pro
soybean and infamil have selenium in
them. And uh it's tragic that we give
our dogs 40 minerals and our rats 28 and
our kids 12 or less. You can begin to
see why we spent $1.2 trillion for
health care last year. You begin to see
why we only live to be 75.5, half of our
genetic potential for longevity of 120
to 140. Why we only rank 17th in
longevity and 19th in healthfulness
simply because we don't get the basic
raw materials to develop properly and
maintain repair cells from the very
beginning. I'll give you a tragic
example. Sudden infant death syndrome is
something that everybody is familiar
with. We eliminated sudden infant death
syndrome and animals back in the 1950s
because farmers can't afford to lose two
or three or five or 10% of the baby
animals are raising to sudden infant
death syndrome. We learned that it was
due to a deficiency of the trace mineral
selenium causing sudden death in the
most robust and the healthiest of the
baby animals in in the group or the herd
of the flock. And we eliminate it simply
by giving the pregnant mothers selenium.
And as soon as the baby is born or
hatched, they get selenium. And if you
look at the human infant milk replacers
on the market, only two of all of them
put selenium in the formula. And so if I
was going to raise a child today on
these infant milk replacers, these
infant milk formulas in a can or a
bottle or a box, I would pick the two
pro soybean and infamilill that have
selenium in them and to stack things in
favor of the child. I would still give
them from the moment they're born a
teaspoon for 20 pounds of body weight of
the pig or thrus from twice a day.
Obviously, you may not want to use the
orange juice in a newborn baby because
they can develop allergies to it, but I
would still give them the plant derived
chloral and the chilated minerals and
vitamins and amino acids. And the tragic
example of this is 65%, this is a known
fact, 65% of all the babies dying of
sudden infant death syndrome in America
are being fed canned milk replacers.
Twothirds of the ones who die of sudden
infant death syndrome are being fed
these canned infant formulas. And I
guarantee you they're being fed the ones
that don't have selenium in them. And so
uh absolutely it's important to
supplement these babies from birth
because you can't get everything you
need from your four food groups.
Certainly not out of these canned
formulas.
Great. Thank you.